i stand shafani
ariana grande is so here for shifani
thank you in a new blooper clip from the
voice the 28 year old singer reveals she
stands blake shelton and his wife and
former voice coach gwen stefani's couple
name
what's you in gwen's
shafani chicago yeah i didn't hear that
oh i love that
i stand shifani and it's no surprise ari
stands the two prior to joining season
21 of the voice as a coach she revealed
to et that she was a big fan of the show
i have watched many seasons and i love
watching the show it always has the best
energy and it's just such
like wholesome inspiring television and
i love seeing the different voices and
watching so many people start careers
for themselves it's like a beautiful
amazing thing since joining team ari's
roster has been quickly filling up and
it's no secret she wants to come out on
top this is my first season and
i'd like to think that i'm here to win
and i know that you and kelly have
babies but i will have a baby for you to
be on my team
i'm not but i would
i'm kidding i need to fight harder i'm
being too nice there's no disadvantage
when you're ariana grande speaking to
e.t ahead of the season 21 premiere
ari's fellow coaches kelly clarkson john
legend and blake shelton revealed that
they knew she would be tough competition
this season of course she's a threat
yeah of course she's a threat she is
hugely talented hugely successful and
has
and has a uh
a legion legions and legions of fans
that
that know how to use the internet and
vote
everything he just said
so we all knew it coming in i was
prepared i came within battle armor
i prepared to be turned down but it was
it was fun though and while ari may be a
threat this year clearly blake hasn't
let that affect his ego with over 200
artists coached in 29 number one hits
and your eight-time boys champion
king
blake
[Applause]
[Music]
you